there is one silver lining to talk about
from yesterday's abortive election and
it's the legalization of marijuana
continuing to expand as several states
voted to legalize recreational and in
some cases medical marijuana in
California Massachusetts and Nevada we
have seen the legalization of
recreational marijuana yesterday in
Arkansas North Dakota and Florida now we
are going to see legal medical marijuana
it's still a little early to say what's
happening in Arizona Maine in Montana at
least as of right now but this is a very
positive trend in favor of the
legalization of marijuana it's part of a
larger trend across the country here in
Massachusetts it was called question
four I voted in favor of it now that I
hear that one of you guys changed your
mind at the last minute and voted and
against legalization I'm going to get a
lot of hate for this so I'm kind of
hesitant to explain why well I think
yeah Wow I am definitely against mass
incarceration I'm good I am completely
against that however there are certain
aspects of it that I was a little bit
worried about for instance I was
thinking okay we don't exactly know the
long-term effects on the brain
especially for young people who were
starting to use marijuana I was also
thinking about what's going to happen to
the black market because when people are
paying taxes they're going to want to
default to the black market now why
didn't you come to me with these
questions Rachel because that would
explain to you that it we have a total
black market when it's illegal so then
when you when you create a legal market
a black market will still exist but it
becomes far smaller so that's a good
thing right but I've also heard of
instances where it also can expose the
market to different types of drugs I
have heard that before
you've heard that yes okay Donald I'm
sorry Rachel but and and the other thing
that you what was the first thing you
mentioned the effect on kids yeah it's
this is gonna be regulated you can't
even go into a dispensary
unless you're 21 years old but I think
if it's legal they're going to be able
to get their hands on it much more
easily more easily I don't know because
now think about it if you're a 21 year
old right and someone asks you to go buy
them buy pot for them number one why
would they even ask you because it's all
a black market it's illegal for anybody
to be buying it on the street so so you
wouldn't need to be asked if now it's
regulated and you have a
hard that you have to turn in and and
there's there's more and more public
cameras and surveillance if you have an
actual legal you know purchase card or
whatever for medical marijuana for
example you're not going to risk losing
that to get some fifteen-year-old some
pot are you I think this makes it less
likely that you would see people buying
for kids okay are more people going to
be operating vehicles when they're high
well that's already happening and so
they're going to increase because they
won't be worried about a penalty for in
Colorado it hasn't and it's it would
still be illegal to drive under the
influence the the problem is Pat as I
think you and I've talked about that
there's no specific testing standard for
what it means to be under the influence
of marijuana that is more of a technical
question that's going to have to be
resolved but that's the thing I think
confuses a lot of people it's already
illegal to do that and I think by
regulating this and putting it out into
the open people take it more seriously
and don't mess around with this type of
nonsense right driving while high is a
very different issue than being able to
use marijuana in the comfort of your own
home and me personally I just take the
libertarian approach on this if you're
not affecting other people negatively
you should be able to do to your body
what you want I'm sure some people will
point out that it may raise health costs
among everyone but there's really no
science to show that marijuana is too
dangerous now at what point did you
change your mind on this Rachel because
you said that you were voting YES oh
yeah I was voting YES and then at the
very last minute I kind of had my mother
in my ear but I mean all of your points
make sense and I definitely I feel
persuaded on some of them I need to find
that article about the the black-market
exposing to other drugs as well so I can
send that to you but I don't know now
I'm feeling a little bit more mixed on
it oh good because I mean here's the
good thing the good thing is it didn't
come down to one vote it overwhelmingly
won so in the end Rachel's mom convinced
him her to vote the other way did not
turn legal marijuana in Massachusetts
the other direct I'm just going to get a
lot of hate now